der Stadthafen von Wedel wird seit fast
10 Jahren umgebaut am Ende werden hier
mindestens 34,9 Millionen Euro
verbuddelt aber auf dem Wasser herrscht
seit Jahren tote Hose denn bis heute ist
es der Stadt nicht gelungen einen
Hafenbetrieb auf die Beine zu stellen
also ich fand das von Anfang an Quatsch
dieses umgebaut da die Salbe so nichts
Ganzes früher waren das Schiffe Boote
drin und jetzt ist alles leer für uns
ist es eigentlich für die
alteingesessenen wedland trauriges Bild
früher hatte diese Hafen Charme es waren
Stege es waren alte Boote es werden
immer mehr Millionen versenkt in diesem
Hafen die man sinnvoller anbringen
könnte und ich denke mal dass das Geld
ist zum Fenster rausgeschmissen
eigentlich sollte hier längst alles
voller Steganlagen Boote und Anleger
sein stattdessen gähnende Lehre fürs
maritime Flair sorgen allenfalls ein
paar Möwen die Schiffe fahren achtlos
vorbei seit knapp zehn Jahren wird an
dem Hafen rum gebaut und seit Jahren
sucht die verzweifelt ein Betreiber für
den Hafen aber in ganz Europa will sich
niemand die Anlage ans Bein binden nun
hat die Kommune eine
machbarkeitsstudienauftrag gegeben
Ergebnis der Hafen wird niemals
kostendecken zu betreiben sein
unglaublich das merkt man erst nach zehn
Jahren von daher wundert mich dass jetzt
erst eine Machbarkeitsstudie gemacht
worden ist das hätte ich viel eher
erwartet mit dem vernünftigen Ergebnis
finde es nur schade diese Anlage könnte
viel mehr Spaß machen einen aktuell
macht sie keinen Spaß es ist eher in
disaster weil sich kein Betreiber findet
könnte die Stadt das selbst in die Hand
nehmen schreibt die Studie und dafür
nochmal 3 Millionen Euro ausgeben für
Steg und Anleger im Zweifel wird dies
von der Stadt Wedel als städtische
Infrastruktur angeschoben werden müssen
hierfür können nach aktuellen
Erkenntnissen zusätzliche Fördergelder
abgerufen werden
aha weitere Fördermillionen für einen
Hafen den offensichtlich so keiner
braucht ich glaube die Leute selber
wissen nicht mehr was sie damit machen
sollen weil zehn Jahre ist ja auch eine
lange Zeit also da fragt man sich
wirklich ob die Leute vorher überlegen
oder nicht Geld rausgeschmissen für
nichts in meinen Augen übrigens laut
Plakette auf den Sitzgelegenheiten am
Hafenbecken ist die Sanierung schon
längst abgeschlossen auch hier muss man
wohl noch mal ran und die richtige
Jahreszahl einsetzen wann immer das sein
wird